hey everybody I'm Rob Overmyer producer
on neverwinter and today we'll be
talking about what's coming up next our
focus is mainly PvP for our next update
and we'll be looking at better cues a
little bit of a stat revamp and new PvP
gear set for PvP cues and matchmaking
our goal is to improve the balance of
tina's we want to use class gear score
and several other mechanics to ensure
the best match and fun fights
additionally we're going to implement a
libra penalty believer penalty affects
players that leave pvp matches early
this will greatly improve PvP matches in
gameplay another aspect of the update is
a look at PvP stats and resistance will
be implementing the staff health
tenacity tenacity should really help
players guard against burst damage and
critical strikes will be adding the
statue all existing PvP gear and will
help differentiate PvE and PvP gear a
bit more we're also looking at crowd
control abilities like knocks and stuns
our goal is to balance the effects of
these powers so players can get up fast
and back in the fight last but not least
we'll be adding a new tier of pvp gear
you can earn the new gear through
participation in domination matches and
gauntlgrym we are really excited about
these PDP changes check them out on the
preview shard and look forum to go live
early 2014
you